David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 9-143C. Father Ioan Kharchenko. It starts with a few sentences introducing Mr. Paulis that he yields the interview to Father Kharchenko. Chicago, October, the 7th, 1950. Boder. [pause]
David Boder: Spool 143, starting at the 23rd minute, the interview is of Alfonsas Paulis, a Lithuanian, thirty three years old, at the Baltic DP camp in Munich, at Lohengrinstrasse.
David Boder: [In Russian] Идите сюда. Скажите нам сперва по-литовски, где Вы были, и что с Вами случилось, когда Совет пришли в Литвению.
Alfonsas Paulis: Я...[неразборчиво; пауза]
David Boder: [In English] September 21, 1946. We are...we interrupt the interview with Alfonsas Paulis...because the Greek Orthodox Minister of the Displaced Persons Camps at Lohengrinstrasse, Munich came in on appointment, he has services I suppose in the evening and we will get a short interview with him. The interview of course will take place in Russian. His name is Father Ioan Shardrenko. Shardrenko or Sharden’ko?
Ioan Kharchenko: [In Russian] Хар-ченко
David Boder: [In English] Oh,...so, Ioan Kharchenko. I will write it down in Russian. [Пауза]
David Boder: [In Russian] Так, подвиньтесь немножко сюда. [Пауза] Скажите мне, отец Иоанн, откуда Вы и как Вы...и откуда Вы из России?
Ioan Kharchenko: Из Вильна.
David Boder: Так, а где Вы были священником, когда произошла эта...мм...немецко-советское советский договор?
Ioan Kharchenko: Немецко-советский договор когда был, я был в это время священником в Риге, в женском монастыре.
David Boder: Вы, значит, тогда были в Прибалтийском крае, в Риге, в женском монастыре. Ну, хорошо, начнете с этого и скажите нам, что с Вами случилось, когда Советы вошли в Прибалтийский край?
Ioan Kharchenko: Когда Советы пришли в Прибалтийский край, то сначала всё было хорошо. А потом постепенно начались...ммм...репрессии. Сначала стали исчезать люди, оказалось, что они арестованы, а потом в конце уже пребывания Советской власти э...стали массами людей куда-то увозить, в центр, вглубь Советской России. Преимущественно люди были привилегированных классов.
David Boder: А скажите мне, как велика была православная группа в Латвии во время независимости Латвии?
Ioan Kharchenko: Во время независимости Латвии в Латвии было полностью свободное православие, никем не преследуемое, и каждый...выполнял свой культ в независимости от того, православлен ли он, иудеен ли он, магометанин—свободно, значит, мог выполнять свои культурные надобности.
David Boder: Да, я хотел знать, сколько православных было тогда в Латвии?
Ioan Kharchenko: Я затрудняюсь сказать.
David Boder: Затрудняетесь сказать. Был у Вас архиерей?
Ioan Kharchenko: У нас был архиепископ Иоанн Поммер, которого неизвестным образом нашли сожженным у себя в вилле.
David Boder: Когда?
Ioan Kharchenko: Уже в 34-ом году. Потом после этого был митрополит Августин, который здравствует и поныне и находится здесь в Германии сейчас.
David Boder: А где он находится?
Ioan Kharchenko: [Пауза] Я не знаю, правда, точно...
David Boder: Он не установил, так сказать, контору такую...
Ioan Kharchenko: Нет, нет.
David Boder: Консисторию не установил?
Ioan Kharchenko: Нет, у него...он принадлежит тоже к нашей церкви, здесь же.
David Boder: Ага, так. Так что он официально тут, так сказать, пока не фигурирует.
Ioan Kharchenko: Да.
David Boder: А. Ну, а расскажите вот что: старые православные соборы все остались православными после независимости Латвии?
Ioan Kharchenko: Я могу сказать только про Ригу, что там, значит, собор как таковой так и остался. Только, значит, дома, в которых жило духовенство, было отчуждено в пользу государства. Даже было время, когда владыка Августин жил одно время в подвальном помещении собора и принимал даже одного из патриархов, приехавших к нему, кажется, Константинопольского, тоже самое в подвале.
David Boder: Но это было при латышах?
Ioan Kharchenko: Это было при латышах.
David Boder: Так, ну, значит, когда Советы пришли, что, латышское правительство переменилось или что это было?
Ioan Kharchenko: Нет, наступила Советская власть.
David Boder: Наступила Советская власть. [Неразборчиво] Значит, когда в первый раз Советы пришли?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, да.
David Boder: Ну, и что тогда с церквами, случилось?
Ioan Kharchenko: С церквами они еще ничего не успели сделать и, по-моему, они еще ничего не делали.
David Boder: А сколько времени они там были?
Ioan Kharchenko: Около года.
David Boder: И они церкви оставляли в покое.
Ioan Kharchenko: Церкви были в покое.
David Boder: Но у Вас же был приход. Что Вы замечали, случалось с Вашими прихожанами?
Ioan Kharchenko: Прихожане, по-моему, нор...церковь посещали нормально, так как и посещают. Но [пауза] в конце уже пребывания Советской власти много прихожан наших поисчезло, и потом, как оказалось, они были высланы вглубь Советского Союза.
David Boder: Так, ну а теперь скажите мне, как состоялся это исход Советов из Латвии? [пауза] Под напоров немцев, очевидно.
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, конечно.
David Boder: Что с Вами тогда произошло? Как с Вашим...с Вами лично.. как Ваши личные обстоятельства были? Ваша личная жизнь во время этого переходного периода?
Ioan Kharchenko: Видите, с нами вместе жил митрополит Сергий.
David Boder: Какой это Сергий был?
Ioan Kharchenko: Которого вот в 44-ом году в июне месяце убили.
David Boder: Ну да, какой это митрополит Сергий был? Он сперва был митрополитом где?
Ioan Kharchenko: В Москве.
David Boder: Он был митрополитом или епископом?
Ioan Kharchenko: Архиепископом.
David Boder: Архиепископ Сергей в Москве.
Ioan Kharchenko: Да.
David Boder: И как он попал в Латвию?
Ioan Kharchenko: Его прислала Советская власть, вернее его прислал патриарх Московский.
David Boder: Так, во время этого Советского...
Ioan Kharchenko: Пребывания.
David Boder: . . . пребывания в Латвии...
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, да...
David Boder: Вот так. И что? Ваша церковь его признала?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, конечно. Мы...постольку, поскольку Латвийская церковь была автономной церковью, то она признала Московского патриарха и его признала как, значит, экзарха Прибалтики. Но потом, когда уходили Советы, то он прятался трое суток в подвале, в монастыре прятался, остался, когда пришли немцы, и значит, объявил автономную церковь, отделённую от Москвы.
David Boder: Так. Ну, и тогда что случилось? Во время немцев как было положение Вас и Ваших прихожан?
Ioan Kharchenko: Видите, в первое время в отношении...во время, когда пришли немце, то особенно не замечалось давления немецкого...[пауза]
David Boder: На церковь?
Ioan Kharchenko: На церковь. Но это очень немного. А потом после этого, значит, немцы, вернее, немецкие вот эти гражданские части, и латышские части начали повсюду, значит, совать свой нос.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: Эээ...я постольку, поскольку служил в первое время при немцах в женском монастыре и был близок около владыки Сергия, знаю, что, значит, они его всячески преследовали.
David Boder: Немцы и латыши?
Ioan Kharchenko: Немцы и латыши. Даже были случаи, когда, значит, заставляли некоторых монашек и некоторую обслугу церкви и монастыря, значит, следить за митрополитом Сергием, считая его советским шпионом.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: На самом деле, конечно, никаким он шпионом не был, и мы в этом глубоко были убеждены. И даже сейчас смерть его, хотя немцы старались обрисовать это террористическим актом Советского Союза, но мы так у себя в душе убеждены, что смерть, значит, его убили, очевидно, немцы, значит, при помощи латышей.
Ioan Kharchenko: Инсценировали только, значит, набег советских партизан.
David Boder: Скажите, Вы человек, имели возможность обозревать все это. Скажите, каково было отношение латышей к Советам? Опишите латыши сперва к Советам, а потом к немцам. Начните с Советов.
Ioan Kharchenko: Значит, с Советов. Латыши, по моему мнению, латыши к Советам относились, когда пришли Советы, хорошо.
David Boder: Так. [Пауза] А было много...?
Ioan Kharchenko: Когда латыши...
David Boder: Да.
Ioan Kharchenko: Когда латыши...когда Советы стали латышей вывозить вглубь страны, в это время подошли и немцы, латыши стали относится к немцам хорошо.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: И до конца, значит...все время с немцами имели большую спайку, большую дружбу.
Ioan Kharchenko: Ну, а что значит, свидетельствует, что Латышская армия существовала такая же на правах немецкой.
David Boder: Что они были как СС?
Ioan Kharchenko: Я право не знаю.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: Я в военных делах...
David Boder: Так, не понимаете...
Ioan Kharchenko: . . . не разбираюсь.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: Но они, значит, масса латышей было военных, и там у них мобилизации были, они числились как немцы.
David Boder: Позвольте, прежде чем я забуду. В этом...в Риге был пастор Фетлер.
Ioan Kharchenko: Да. Это баптисткий?
David Boder: Баптист. Что с ним случилось?
Ioan Kharchenko: Я не знаю, я...[неразборчиво]
David Boder: Вы не имели, Вы случайно не знаете, что с ним случилось?
Ioan Kharchenko: Нет, понятия не имею.
David Boder: Да, я только хотел [неразборчиво]...
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, да.
David Boder: . . . потому что у него есть масса друзей в Америке, и они, пожалуй, хотели бы знать. Ну, а скажите как вот что: теперь...эту...когда немцы [пауза]. Дайте мне задать другой вопрос: знали Вы—или мы придем к этому—знали Вы что-нибудь о том, что немецкие...немцы делали с евреями в Латвии?
Ioan Kharchenko: Э, я как раз был около.. служил в монастыре, где рядом находилось гетто немецкое...эээ еврейское.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: И у меня было очень много знакомых евреев, которые находились в гетто, преимущественно интеллигентные.
Ioan Kharchenko: Причем мы с женой специально вставали очень рано утром, для того чтоб только повидать их, когда их вели утром на работы.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: И значит тайным образом мы им кланялись, и они нам отвечали тоже самое, уже пройдя мимо. Если только заметили бы немцы наши поклоны им, то нас бы тоже или бы посадили в гестапо, или бы посадили в гетто, считая...
David Boder: Евреями?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да.
David Boder: Ну, а чем же кончилось эта судьба этих людей?
Ioan Kharchenko: Их очень много увозили, даже говорят, были слухи, что очень многих там уничтожали, но каким образом—об этом не говорили. Но очень много увозили в другие куда-то места. В конечном итоге евреев в момент уже 43го года сравнительно было мало, когда по утрам их водили на работы.
David Boder: Так. Вы семью Мехельсонов не знали в Риге?
Ioan Kharchenko: Я знаю...я скрывал там одного еврея до настоящего времени в Риге. Это бывший бывший присяжный поверенный, мы ему подделали документы немца, и он, значит...эээ...
David Boder: Жил?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, так и жил в...
David Boder: Как же фамилия была?
Ioan Kharchenko: Его фамилия была Шмит, как раз подходила под немца. [пауза]
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: Причем, для того, чтоб спастись, и, так сказать, так они посещали наш монастырь и, так сказать, полностью выдавали себя за православных немцев. Так они сейчас в Риге и остались.
David Boder: Ага. Анна Владимировна [not quite clear whether it’s a name or other words].
David Boder: [In English] This concludes spool 143. We are going over to spool 144 still with the interview of Father Ioan Kharchenko.
David Boder: [In Russian] Один момент...[Unclear sounds.]
David Boder: [In English] This is spool 144, spool 144 continued the interview with the Russian minister Ioan Kharchenko.
David Boder: [In Russian] Скажите, отец Иоанн, значит это [пауза]...дальше что случилось, когда немцы начали уходить? Или вообще, дайте-ка мне оценку положения во время Вашего там, так сказать, междуцарствия власти.
Ioan Kharchenko: Когда немцы стали уходить из Латвии, то у нас у всех получилось такое положение, что оставаться в Латвии—это значит быть, наверняка быть расстрелянным большевиками. Потому что мы, оставшись при...от...при уходе большевиков из Латвии, являлись уже изменниками для Советской власти.
David Boder: Один момент. Скажите-ка мне, что случилось с архиереем? Там Вы мне говорили, что...
Ioan Kharchenko: В мае месяце убили митрополита Серафима между...в то время, когда он направлялся из Вильна в Ковно через, значит...эээ...автомобилем.
David Boder: Он, что, был в духовной одежде?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, он был в духовной одежде, с ним вместе был один знаменитый бард...эээ...и жена барда, этого артист был, фамилию его я сейчас не помню.
David Boder: Его тоже убили?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, и шофер. Четыре человека. Убили четверых человек. И девочка стояла примерно метров 200 от того места происшествия. Эту девочку семилетнюю тоже самое бандиты убили.
David Boder: Так. Это был тот архиепископ, который был прислан из Москвы, а потом остался в Риге?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, да, это тот архи...это тот митрополит.
David Boder: Митрополит. Ну, хорошо, продолжайте, значит, свою историю.
Ioan Kharchenko: Значит, когда немцы стали уходить, то у нас у каждого было такое впечатление, что остаться в Риге—это значит быть наверняка уничтоженным Советской властью, так как мы являлись уже противниками Советской власти, постольку, поскольку при уходе Советских войск не ушли вместе с ними. В одно и то же время не хотелось покидать Ригу, так как ехать куда-то в неизвестность, тем более к немцам, которых мы уже за полтора-два года пребывания их в Латвии изучили и узнали, что это исклю...это это нация, которая исключительно только занимается агрессией и порабощением человечества. И [пауза] должны были выбрать что-то...из двух зол лучшую. Но и этого нам не пришлось делать, так как...эээ...немцы в обязательном порядке заставили всех эвакуироваться, причем, посадив нас на пароходы, отправили в Германию. А в Германии заперли нас вот в лагерях, и для того, чтобы мы не могли сбежать из этих лагерей, обнесенных тройной проволокой, каждого...каждому из нас по приезде на грудь номера и номер лагеря, и фотографировали. После этого, не взирая на специальность и общественное положение, посылали всех на общие работы, и зачастую разъединяли семьи, увозя детей и матерей куда-то в одну сторону, а глав семьи—мужей—отправ..., и сыновей - отправляя в другую сторону. Причем, когда мою семью увезли, я не знал, куда её увезли в августе месяце, и только случайно, сбежав из этого лагеря, узнал, что моя семья находится в городе Авербахе, в [неразборчиво], работает на швейной фабрике как «остовцы». «Остовцы» - это значит, эээ...принудительные рабочие с востока.
David Boder: Ост?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, да, да. «Ост» назывались.
David Boder: Расскажите-ка мне более подробно о жизни в лагере: как Вас транспортировали? Как с Вами обращались? И как вы убежали из лагеря?
Ioan Kharchenko: Мне лично пришлось транспортироваться не на пароходе, а поездом. Так что мне пришлось ехать на Ковно, значит, в товарных вагонах, в Ковно нас отправили до Кретингена, а в Кретингене нас высадили, и мы две недели валялись на железной дороге, на станции, форменным образом между рельс, так как все немцы бежали, и все составы поездов были заняты. Мы же остались...эта двадцати тысячная толпа осталась беспризорной, нас не кормили, и значит, мы просуществовали так, как кто как чем может.
David Boder: Вот как это...что это было «как чем может»?
Ioan Kharchenko: Это было, значит, что мы вели полуголодное существование. Причем, нас всячески заставляли на границе в Кретингене идти на работы копать окопы. Но мы всеми правдами и неправдами старались этого избежать и все-таки, значит, на рытьё окопов не пошли. [Пауза]
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: После этого нас бросили на произвол судьбы. Но когда уходили последние части, уже подрывные какие-то, которые взрывали станции, то дали возможность нам собрать скотские открытые платформы, и значит, этими...на этих...на эти открытые платформы погрузили нас, прицепили маленький паровозик местного сообщения, и из Кретингена до Мемеля—18 км - нас везли 12 часов. Причем все время нашей эвакуации от Риги до Берлина была большая и очень строгая стража. Так что, если только кто хотел бежать, то, значит, с ним поступали очень жестоко, избивали его, а были случаи даже и убийств. Ну, а уже о том, когда нас привезли в Берлин, я сказал. Нас привезли в Вильхельмсхаген, так называемый пересыльный лагерь, это в котором имеется три двора. Первый двор пере...эээ...там только переночуешь ночь, а потом ведут во второй двор, и третий внутренний. И оттуда уже выхода нет, кроме как куда-то, как закабаленного раба на одну из немецких военных фабрик.
David Boder: А как обращались с людьми?
Ioan Kharchenko: Обращались по-скотски.
David Boder: Били?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, били. Очень плохо кормили, и вообще был полный произвол. Работать заставляли невзирая на часы, а кормили исключительно только брюквой, вернее, водой от брюквы, и давали хлеба не более ста грамм в сутки.
David Boder: А кто были надзиратели? Были Ваши русские? Латыши? Или немцы?
Ioan Kharchenko: Нет, вот в Вильхельмсхагене были надзирателями русская молодежь из подсоветских. Нужно сказать, что даже были случаи, когда наши же русские барышни, продаваясь немцам, получая, так сказать, некоторое благосостояние временное, всячески старались прижимать и угнетать своих же братьев русских. Не только русских, но и всех остальных. Там были и латыши, там были и литовцы, там были и эстонцы, там были поляки. Нужно сказать, что к полякам еще хуже относились. Ну, и было очень обидно, когда в Вильхельмсхагене какая-то русская девчонка 16 -17 лет, но пользующаяся у шефа этого лагеря благорасположением, била по физиономии какого-нибудь старого профессора. В остальных лагерях, уже в рабочих лагерях, на фабриках и заводах, надзирателями были сами немцы. И там еще хуже, еще грубее была дисциплина. Жестче относились к разным провинностям невинным, уходить было...эээ...из общежития самого лагеря нельзя, а если и отпускали, может быть в месяц, два месяца раз на час, на два в город, то никто не имел права ехать на трамвае или омнибусе, а должен был идти по середине улицы посреди улицы пешком.
David Boder: А какую одежду Вы носили?
Ioan Kharchenko: Носили одежду свою, но только носили знак...знак...голубой такой знак на груди с белыми буквами «Ост».
David Boder: «Ост». Ну, хорошо. А как же Вы удрали из лагеря?
Ioan Kharchenko: Мне из лагеря удалось удрать...
David Boder: Вы бороду сохранили или...?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, да, я был...я был тогда уже полностью в духовном...
David Boder: Облачении?
Ioan Kharchenko: . . . облачении. И я в канцелярии узнал о том, что...эээ...мне как духовному лицу можно будет из Вил...из лагеря в Вильхельмсхагене поехать в кафедральный собор помолиться Богу. У меня был мой друг, инженер Корабликов, которого я попросил, если я не вернусь обратно...эээ...мои вещички, которые у меня были, потом мне каким-нибудь образом переслать, а сам получил пропуск, ушел вечером в субботу в собор кафедральный, пере...попросил митрополита меня оставить и больше в лагерь не вернулся.
David Boder: А как? Митрополит там был на свободе?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, митрополит был...
David Boder: немцем.
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, да, митрополит германский. Он был на свободе, в кафедральном соборе в городе.
David Boder: Ага. Ну, и что же тогда случилось?
Ioan Kharchenko: Ну, после этого я в лагерь не вернулся. Недели две я ночевал на станциях, на Фридрихштрассе, Александерплатц, а потом...
David Boder: А что же? Вас не арестовали? Документов не просили?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, тогда была, знаете...как сказать? Ну...более...
David Boder: Легкой?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, безалаберщина была, постольку, поскольку немцы уже чувствовали, что у них дисциплина уже падает.
David Boder: Где, в каком городе это было?
Ioan Kharchenko: В Берлине.
David Boder: Ага.
Ioan Kharchenko: Станции все были загружены солдатами, дезертирами, сравнительно свободно было. Но потом мне все-таки наш эмигрантский комитет достал комнатку и...
David Boder: Власть еще все немецкая была?
Ioan Kharchenko: Немецкая власть.
David Boder: И бомбардировали город?
Ioan Kharchenko: Каждый день по нескольку раз. Ну, потом недели через две мне достали документ. Мне...потом достали мне комнатку, и я, значит, до прихода американцев, вернее, до начала февраля, до самой большой бомбардировки, жил в Берлине, а потом узнал, где моя семья и 9 февраля выехал к своей семье в Авербах, где и встретили меня американцы.
David Boder: А...А когда Вас в Авербахе встретили американцы?
Ioan Kharchenko: 6 апреля 1945 года.
David Boder: Хорошо. Что Вы тогда сделали?
Ioan Kharchenko: Там...Американцы мне дали возможность сейчас же организовать там православную церковь, предоставив в мое распоряжение маленькую католическую кирху.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: И я там служил до тех пор, пока не пожелал поехать в лагерь...
Ioan Kharchenko: ..где нахожусь и до настоящего времени.
David Boder: А, значит, Вы уже более года здесь в лагере?
Ioan Kharchenko: Нет, я не...я был в Нюрнбергском лагере, а, значит, здесь я восемь месяцев.
David Boder: И что же? Вы тут церковь имеете?
Ioan Kharchenko: То же самое: имею великолепную церковь, оборудованную оборудованную нашими собственными силами.
David Boder: Какие-нибудь иконы вывезли? Имеете их?
Ioan Kharchenko: Икон мы никаких..., но мы сами здесь рисуем. И наши иконы позавидуют старинным.
David Boder: А Вы знаете, что в доме, где это УННРА обедают, я сегодня видел очень старинную русскую икону с серебряной ризой, которую, очевидно, немцы вывезли из России?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, я встречал здесь тоже у некоторых знакомых немцев, когда приходилось с ними встречаться,...эээ...тоже встречал русские иконы, и они мне их показывали.
David Boder: Но их не давали?
Ioan Kharchenko: Нет, они мне их не давали, ибо они считают это ценностью материальной. И мне в большинстве случаев немцы говорили, что это их родственники, будучи в России, значит, присылали оттуда подарки.
David Boder: Это краденое добро?
Ioan Kharchenko: Совершенно правильно.
David Boder: А Вы что, тут знаете немцев кое-каких?
Ioan Kharchenko: Нет, я вот так бывает случайно, приходится встретиться, иной раз обменять что-нибудь. Приходил обменять вещи на продукты. У бауеров имеются продукты, а мы очень голодали...
David Boder: У крестьян это?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, у крестьян.
David Boder: Скажите мне вот что: Вы много с немцами встречались, и с другими встречались. Что они про войну думали и думают?
Ioan Kharchenko: По-моему, немцы...эээ...столетиями являлись агрессорами.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: Я лично не политик, но я считаю так, что немцы [пауза] всегда думали о том, как бы поработить Европу.
Ioan Kharchenko: И если они сейчас только...эээ...до некоторый степени молчат, потому что их разбили в пух и прах, то все равно, обосновываясь опять материально, они опять будут...будут заводить речи о том, что они чистая арийская раса, а остальные все являются «унтерменшами».
David Boder: Так. Они что, употребляли это выражение «унтерменш»?
Ioan Kharchenko: Не только употребляли, но я сам читал журнал—у них очень хорошая обложка, красивая и...эээ...на хорошей на хорошей бумаге был отпечатан—журнал «Унтерменш», где они...
David Boder: Так назывался журнал?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, так и назывался официально....Где они, значит, показывали типы разных народов, преимущественно дегенератов и указывали: это русский, это еврей, это...эээ...татарин, это украинец, а рядом ставили какого-нибудь эсесовца и писали: «А это чистый ариец—немец».
David Boder: Так. Так что Вы не думаете, что они раскаиваются, что что-нибудь произошло и так далее? Что они мир там бросили в море крови и так далее...раскаялись, что...
Ioan Kharchenko: По-моему, по-моему, если только и раскаиваются немцы, то очень малое количество, малый процент. Они и сейчас на нас смотрят как на...эээ...чуждый для них элемент, не нужный им элемент, хотя во всех несчастьях и во всех бедах виноваты они...они, и то правительство, которое заставило нас покинуть Родину. И все-таки они здесь не дают возможности нам тоже быть полноправными сейчас, хотя они это сейчас открыть не выявляют, но во всех их действиях, во всех их движениях, во всем поведении видно, как они нас ненавидят. Достаточно того, что если сядешь в трамвай, если заходит...я в духовной одежде, мне никогда никто из немцев не предложит...эээ...
David Boder: Места.
Ioan Kharchenko: . . . места. В одно и то же время мой дьякон в штатской форме едет со мной. Немцы, принимая его за немца, сейчас же предложили ему...эээ...
David Boder: Место.
Ioan Kharchenko: . . . место.
David Boder: Так.
Ioan Kharchenko: И когда он не садясь, стал мне предлагать по-русски, то они увидали, что это тоже ауслендер и заняли опять свое же место и не стали нам давать возможности сесть. Вот такие мелоча у них проявляются во всем. Не только к русским или к полякам, к евреям, но даже и к тем немцам, которые сейчас выехали с...Польши, считая, что это люди, которые уже более или менее, так сказать, овосточились.
David Boder: Так. И низшей культуры?
Ioan Kharchenko: Да, и низшей культуры стали.
David Boder: Ну, хорошо, отец Иоанн. Эээ...Есть еще кое-что, что бы Вы хотели сказать? Хотели бы что-нибудь сказать Вашим Чикагским братьям, Чикагскому духовенству? Скажите..
Ioan Kharchenko: Я бы хотел сказать, чтобы...[пауза] Наши братья во Христе, спасите нас, спасите от того произвола [пауза], в котором мы находимся уже 27 лет. Мы страдаем, мы мучаемся, мы потеряли Родину, мы потеряли зачастую семьи, мы потеряли все имущество. Мы сейчас получаем ни...как нищий милостыню кусок хлеба [пауза], не смотря на то, что тысячи нас, интеллигенции, тысячи инженеров, тысячи профессоров [пауза] сидят сейчас, не применяя своего труда. А сколько б они могли принести пользы человечеству. Но этого мало. [Пауза] Еще одно, что нас ждет, и ждет самое ужасное: мы привыкли уже ко всем лишениям, но возврат обратно, на Родину, возврат к отцу народов Сталину для нас грозит неминуемой смертью. И если, братья во Христе, вы нам не поможете, если Вы нас не вырвите отсюда, если Вы нас не...не возьмете к себе, то должны будете знать, что многие еще сотни тысяч должны будут лечь костьми там, у себя же на родной земле. Просьба наша к вам: спасите нас, как когда-то Минин и Пожарский сменяли своих...эээ...отдавали все свое добро, даже сказали, что отменяют жен и детей, но все-таки спасут Русь. Так и вы спасите ос...осколки той Руси, которые 27 лет сейчас без ветрил и без руля плавает по великому океану горя и крови. Аминь.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with the Father Ioan Kharchenko at the Displaced People camp of the Baltic in Munich, Lohengrinstrasse, September the 21st, 1946.
David Boder: [In Russian] Спасибо.